If you've decided your
app will be monetized
with in-app advertising,
it's essential to plan
for this early in
your design process.
Ads should fit seamlessly into
the experience of your app
and not interrupt its flow.
The ad type you choose should
depend on the type of content
you're offering and how
your users engage with it.
In this video, we'll
look at your options.
And remember, don't
settle for just one.
Consider mixing and
matching ad types
to fit the structure of
your app and the audience
to provide the best
user experience.
Don't worry, using
AdMob is easy.
To get started, all you
have to do is sign up
on google.com/admob.
Then integrate the
Google Mobile Ads SDK
with three simple steps
from developers.google.com.
And finally, create
your first ad unit code
from your AdMob account.
Next, we'll go over the
variety of innovative ad
formats available to you,
showcasing their features,
and when and where
you'd want to use each.
Let's start with
the smart banner.
This is an ad format that spans
the entire width of the screen
and varies in height, depending
on the size of your screen
device.
Why smart banners?
Well, as people engage with
a wider array of devices,
you will have to adapt to a
multitude of screen sizes.
With smart banners,
these units smartly
detect the width of
your phone or tablet
in its current
orientation and adjust
to the size for
best presentation,
giving users an engaging
experience regardless
of the device they're using.
Next are full-screen
interstitial ads.
They fill the
screen immediately,
presenting rich experiences
at natural app transition
points such as the
end of a game level.
They offer an immersive
experience for users
to see the most engaging
content from advertisers.
They also provide a
simple close button
so that users can easily
return to the app content.
Trueview ads are video ads that
appear in interstitial slots.
Trueview ads have been a
staple of YouTube advertising
for a while now but are now
available for mobile ads.
Once a Trueview
ad appears, users
have the option to watch the ad
or skip it after five seconds.
This is great for advertisers,
publishers, and users.
Users only see the
ads they want to see,
advertisers are connected
with a truly engaged audience,
and publishers get the
benefit of giving their users
a positive user experience
while still making money
from ads that are watched.
What if you want to take
a little more control
of your own inventory and
promote your own products?
You can do that, too.
AdMob's house ad
features give you
a way to grow your in-app
purchasing revenue for free.
You can show users customized
text or display ads promoting
the items you want to sell.
Not every user is going to
make a purchase in your app.
So AdMob automatically figures
out which of your users
are likely to buy based on
Google's advanced data models.
AdMob will then show
those users not likely
to convert regular ads
instead of your house ads.
Native ads are another
innovative ad format
offered in AdMob.
They allow you to match
the formatting, style,
and content of your
app, making for a better
overall experience.
You can customize the form
and function of native ads
to match your app by
implementing the AdMob SDK.
We pay close attention
to user experience.
so our native ads
are designed to be
clearly identifiable as ads
to users, but not intrusive
to the experience of your app.
Thanks for watching.
Be sure to check out
our other AdMob videos,
subscribe to our AdMob channel,
and visit google.com/admob
for more information.
[MUSIC PLAYING]